welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz today i'm
really excited to be joined by jody
marks who is the ceo and founder of the
mrj group who consists of mrj
recruitment and mrj talent jody is also
a non-exec director to a boutique
product delivery business called nebula
and he is also the co-organizer of a
tech event
meetup called tech leads north west
jody has worked in industry since 2001
he started his recruitment career at
huxley and then worked for rillian for a
a good number of years before deciding
to start his own recruitment business
mrj recruitment in 2010 so over the last
decade uh jodi has been really
passionate and focused on growing
a recruitment business that is truly
driven by purpose not profit jody thanks
for joining me on the podcast ah thanks
for having me how you doing
i'm good i'm uh excited to unpack this
this journey of yours so where we uh
always like to start
the uh million pound question
in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you think make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant
okay so i think uh
most people always go oh you gotta be
really money-driven
yeah i just think that's just the wrong
way about thinking about things for me i
think if you do a good job money comes
so i think key things that i always look
for is someone who's actually a bit
humble
and actually understands that actually
we're here to uh
we're dealing with people's lives
so i think people like for me
i hate the push of recruiter i'm all
about consortive approach
people who actually care about other
people for me is is really important but
the big characteristics for you know i
was telling someone the other day in my
team about
no means not yet
so just because someone says no
doesn't mean it's a no forever and
that's how you're building your network
right so i think it's no just may mean
not yet so you've got to keep in touch
with these people so it's like
perseverance all the time and continuing
that uh knowing that you're gonna get
setbacks you're gonna get knockbacks but
you've got to keep going so it's having
that drive to keep pushing and keep
pushing all the time i think that's
really important
uh do you think
like thinking back when you started your
recruitment career 2001
if you were going into that environment
going yeah like i'm not really driven by
money like all this like how would that
overlander do you think how do you think
people would have reacted to that is it
massively changed
uh no i think everyone says the same
thing all the time like it's my most
hated uh
answer when i
interview someone why why are you here
just just want to earn money well you
can go no money anywhere right but if i
go back to like right at the beginning i
had no idea what i wanted to do dropped
out of university
mum and dad were devastated because i
dropped out of university and then
started i was working and actually my
journey was supposed to start in um
in retail so i was working at house of
fraser uh and then um i was gonna go on
the management training course and then
i was told i wasn't allowed to go on it
because i wasn't a graduate oh wow so i
was like all right then i was gonna
leave you then see you later and then
went for an interview one day
which ended up being a recruitment
company and i only went to it at the
beginning because my mom and dad
suddenly did the job and it's about time
i got off my ass that did something i
had no idea what i was going into
so for me i don't actually went into an
open eyes but i remember all these
people it's like it was proper boiler
room
just got a great learning but
i think uh it just comes with experience
knowing that if you do a good job money
will come and i think we get a bad
reputation recruiters because
it's too transactional
in my opinion right so so my style has
always been less transactional more
consultative
and
money you will earn good money if you do
a good job rather than the other way
around does that make sense yeah yeah
yeah for sure so like just really
quickly just keen to like just get your
thoughts on this as we're talking about
it because
i would say most successful recruiters
that i've interviewed on this podcast
definitely would have that mindset and
agree with you so like in your opinion
like
how would you sum up a
recruiter that builds transactional
relationships and how would you sort of
describe a recruiter that's actually
consultative and adds value like what
the how would you paint a picture phrase
of a transactional person and a
consultative person
it's a transactional good question i'd
say the one who would just farm out of
candidates at as many places as they can
don't really care where they end up as
long as they get a deal
and it's all about kpis
so it's about if you send out a
candidate gonna be honest with you so
one of the things we do is mrj talent
right so i'm on site a company right now
um
and there's a there's a couple of
agencies that we're working with so
we're managing a couple of agents on
site and
you know they're just farming our
candidates to me
but they send them out to 10 other
places and they don't really care like
on a friday they're going to get a deal
happy days
but what happens is they're just pushing
them in because it's about the money
whereas me and our approach is less is
more let's find out like a sort of
approach for me is let's really go and
find out
what this candidate is all about where
they actually want to develop and the
amount of times i turn around i've
turned around to loads of people all the
time saying got you the offer i don't
think it's the right job for you
um i've done this right job for you and
i'll tell you why because everything you
told me it's ended up i don't think it's
gonna be the right place for you so i
prefer someone i prefer not to get a
deal but the candidate goes to the right
place rather than just thinking about
the money
which happens and that's that
and the biggest difference i think
between transactional and consultive is
mrj has been built on relationships and
it's not just we just do one deal here
then we move on
it's not just about the 25 feet you do
one and then you move on we're more
about
long-term investment in clients and
our business has been built on
reputation rather than cold calling just
farming people out
so i think it's it's i think it's a a
really
defined difference in my opinion
i honestly like i
like i just can't imagine a
recruitment business
that approaches recruitment that way in
the transactional way to have survived
during covid like i just i just can't i
just don't i can't see how that would
have
i feel like covered in like i feel like
you would have like i don't know i just
can't see how that works how you would
have survived that you know what i think
um
has been a really interesting time i
remember that first day 23rd of march
right
yeah about
uh four o'clock i was pulling my hair
out like everyone was and i was glass of
wind up and i don't think i've stopped
since but i think um
i just took around to my team and said
look honestly we're not gonna panic
we're not going to panic because we've
got these strong relationships and our
style of what we do we're going to come
out of it in the right way what i've
noticed is
a lot of companies because of that style
the transactional which is kpis you've
got to make xml calls you've got to do
this you've got to do that you've got to
do that
they struggled quite a bit
now
the market is busy
we've just had our uh biggest ever
quarter
in in 12 months yeah but 12 months ago
you didn't make any money like i know a
few companies that have just done
like year-on-year 12-month figures
and they just had a great quarter
but 12 months ago they did nothing well
12 months ago our style because we had
these big relationships and it was about
that
we we just stayed steady and strong the
whole time yeah we're doing business
yeah yeah i mean so
look there's a place for it don't get me
wrong i think uh there's always a place
for that type of industry but i think
that's where we get that night a bad
name if i'm honest
and um the boiler room style the the the
revolving door as i like to call the
revolving door recruiter which is you're
in and out you've got you've got three
weeks to try and
to try and do a deal otherwise you're
out i think that's coming back again but
that's why recruiters get a bad name in
my opinion
yeah i would definitely like to think
that there's like more companies that
aren't like that than there is but that
i wouldn't be able to say
yeah i don't know like um i've moved
away from
the whole there's just that whole kpi
world where it's all about numbers and
numbers and numbers
it's just never been my thing
yeah sure
so
we're going to talk about you building
your own recruitment business but let's
just touch on so before you
took that leap and started that journey
obviously i started your career at
huxley then worked to
really for yeah nearly nearly a decade
yeah so i guess how would you
i guess one would you mind just sharing
with us like
maybe you could focus on ruling or
whatever just the combined experience
like what were some of the
the key learnings that you took from
because you as you said you went an
open-minded didn't know even recruitment
was a career option i feel like you
probably had a bit of a point to prove
to your parents and your peers that you
dropped out of union you wanted to make
the most of it but like what were some
of the i guess looking back the key
takeaways from that journey before you
start your own recruitment business that
you probably still yeah
live with yes
you know what i joined hudsley
20 people joined on the same day
two months two months later two of us
were left
i
remember i i remember but you know what
these guys and
s3 grouper
made a shitload of money right and
they've done an amazing job and they've
done some brilliant and their models
have changed over time but at that time
it was very
um it was very boilery but i remember
coming in
when we were going off your role in the
training five pound hour and i was like
class got a job gonna go and sell mom
and dad
um
and it was brilliant like i loved it it
was proper work i'll play hard and it
was great for about 18 months and i got
mentored amazingly and i joined really
on
um because my my boss at huxley went to
rudon yeah
and took me with him
um and you know i'm grateful for that
because actually
joining rudolph was just a completely
different experience so when you had
like the proper
vertical based hard-nosed recruitment at
huxley you then went to rouleon which
was all about big client relationships
developing clients
winning winning something large scale
but then nurturing it in a big way
so
i got combined the two
so i was grateful for that opportunity
and i was like you know
um
and i remember so like my old mentor
gareth and you know
grateful for a lot of the stuff that
i've done today has been down to the
training i got from him right at the
beginning
and um if i think about started i went
to rooney on he he
we had a team there was probably a team
about 20 when we joined
but they wanted to change what was going
on in perth because it wasn't quite
working so gareth was brought in
and eventually it was like me me and
gareth and one other
against the rest of the perm team
because we had a different way of doing
it uh but he put his trust in me and i
was only a young lad at that point
um and then over time we built up a very
very strong like the team changed we
built up a super strong perm team
numbers wires are great but we combined
i think what me and gary did we combined
what we what we had of the hooks like
yeah and combine that with really on him
and somewhere in the middle
yeah yeah and it was brilliant so we had
that sort of
there is like there is no second place
but we're going to do that within
nurturing clients
rather than when there is no second
place and then we only just do that one
deal
yeah we just keep developing it further
so i've got some great experience and
learning from that
um
and then i was there worked eight years
nine years at really on uh gareth moved
on
i got um his role
i always thought i'd want it
and then didn't want it
to be honest like i i always thought
yeah be ahead of per recruitment and be
part of senior leadership in a big
company it was great but
it wasn't for me and
what
time to do something else uh
jim on sharing with us
so there's a couple of things i just
want to ask you before we go into
your own um business journey so one
why was it why wasn't it for you just
talk to us a bit about that and how it
felt because i feel like a lot of people
listening to this will be
recruiters that have big goals
aspirations want to develop
that position like what what did it
actually feel like and
i think at the time
i think
i think i probably got the role by
default
even
because he left
garrett left couple of people went gary
set up something else you know and
it was it was the right thing for him
for him to do
um
they needed someone to step in and i did
um
but i didn't feel like i deserved it
i did deserve it but i didn't get the
trust that we needed to how to grow it
right so what happened was
at the time the garage just before gary
left we lost a couple of people then
gareth left with three so we're five
people down
then our target is the same
my basic suddenly has not gone up
and also
my my bill my bonuses are halved
so if you think about is when you go
from a recruiter to a from a consortium
to a manager
your your bonuses well they should be
your bonuses are based on
uh yeah
for the team right yeah yeah you can
imagine you've got two million pound
profit uh two million pound target would
say 20 people
or a two million pound target with
uh 12 people just say
and your top biller was me taken out to
manage the team
and you you've got to hit your two
million to get even not even to get what
i was earning before that was just to
get to 75 percent of what i was earning
so suddenly it was like well only six
people well we're just not ready to
invest in it yet well i'm gonna go then
and i'm going to go well i'm happy you
know what i was like i'm happy to hit
that target
but i just need a couple i wouldn't do
an investment to it
so maybe there wasn't the trustee i
could do it i don't know but i looked
today i remember coming home one night
thinking i'm just not sure that
that uh this is going to be achievable i
think it what it what it made me realize
is that rooney at the time was a very
contract heavy and all about numbers you
know you've got three four thousand
contractors out and perm was a smaller
thing and i think they were happy with
doing that
um
and then i was like okay well then i
remember going back the next day and
they were like right we're going to
increase your basic because i hate well
good
i'm going to increase it from 27 to 30.
i was like
we're going
to you like taking the piss right um so
you give me two and a half grand extra
for manana leading the whole team to
what earn 60 grand from 120 grand
that doesn't really add up to me
uh
and then and then i was like well let's
just see let's just think about it then
i went to a meeting with like the senior
leadership and it was just like
so many politics in that there were too
many politics at a time and i just
thought i can't like i'm like
don't need to do it anymore like
yeah i've always had it i always wanted
to set something up on my own
um
my little girl was 18 months old at that
point and i know i'd like missed a lot
of her first year
because
you know i was so dedicated and doing it
yeah yeah so but my advice is like if
peop
everyone wants to develop
you know
um
just on on this earth just really
quickly because i hear this a lot like
how and i'm sure you thought about this
because you could like this someone
could feel or experience the potential
in your business now like how
like how do you think
businesses can change like how
billing leaders and managers are like
rewarded do you know what i mean like
does it like i don't know like surely
there
there could be a bit more of a creative
way on how they can still earn the money
that they was like is that just part and
parcel of being a manager i don't know
i said no you know what people really
want to develop and i completely
understand that and people want to lead
but what happens is
i think sometimes
people do struggle to go from we've got
a couple of guys in my team people
struggle to go from a consortium to a
manager because it's so hands-on and i
and we can talk about like the mrj side
but i struggle with it
yeah so hands-on you mean like you just
want to be involved all the time i just
i just love recruitment i love
i love doing deals right so what happens
is sometimes you go the billing
recruiter
the bit so the billing manager
for me is just a senior consultant with
series of like with some resources i
find it difficult sometimes but maybe
that's just my experience so you need to
if you really i think if you really want
to become the manager
and you want to grow a team my advice is
make sure you know what you're getting
yourself
in for make sure you've got the right
bonus in place and it's achievable
because all that's going to happen is in
12 months time
you're going to end up earning a lot
less money potentially
and
then you start then what happens is you
then fall back into well i need to start
recruiting today
it's a difficult balance i think um it
is difficult i don't know what the
answer is sometimes but i just know that
i i mean one of my guys into uh
into the role of like chief of staff for
md and stuff and he manages everyone he
managed the team and i'm just like more
like the hands-on tech leader in the
world of tech like i'm the hands-on
leader so people follow
um
but
i've just seen it many a time where
you've got people will go from
consortium to manager
and
they don't understand why they're not
earning the same money
because does that have to be the way
i don't think it has to be the way
i don't think it has to be a way like my
guy
one of my guys now is managing you know
he's got a really um
a really strong boat a bonus structure
in place
quarterly bonus that every hit is he
alone more money than he was a
consultant
yeah you know because we're getting
people
he's got something to go to whereas a
lot of the time i i find that you
suddenly get managers you go well you're
a hundred grand
yeah you're gonna win 50
but you've got to do that and then
suddenly you can become a bit hands-on
again and then you don't cope with all
the kpis you've got to do all these
different things
so i think sometimes you've got to good
know that you get you could go into
management role that you may earn less
money for the first year or two
yeah rather than just deep dive getting
back into it if that makes sense
yeah yeah
i just think there's definitely space
there to be a bit creative of how
managers get
rewarded and what the bonus looks like
just because i i just hear this so often
and it's just like
yeah i think i think they should have a
higher bonus structure like i like
i've never understood why
look back in the times of ruling on
there's obviously a bottom line you're
thinking well i'm going to pay someone
30 grand basic right and um as heading
up a team of 12
and uh
he may own 60 grand
but my point at the time was well
pay me a little bit more so i don't need
to worry about the uh my day-to-day
give me a real bonus i can get those to
two million quid with a couple of extra
people
your bottom line your mate you would be
400 grand you're going to make 800 800
profit if we get to that point so pay me
that but i think something like that
yeah yeah yeah i mean so i see that a
lot of the companies go well i'm now
paying someone 50 60 grand as a uh as a
manager
that's a big that's that's heavy that
but my point is when you pay someone 60
but they can only go in 120 or 150 as a
manager if they they're only going to
earn that
if we if we hit those sort of levels so
i prefer to give them those big
opportunities but make it realistic i
think a lot of the time managers but i
think the mindset sometimes is
i'm a consultant i've done it for three
years i want to be a manager
i'm earning 50 rounds 617 whatever it
may be then you become a manager and you
think yes i'm being my manager i don't
know i'm earning a little bit less money
now how's that all work so i think your
mindset has to change you know that you
could become a manager
you may depending on on the investment
you have behind the or the team you have
behind there you could have a slight dip
because it's different
you know sales a salesman
could make more money than your manager
that's just reality that's in every
company that's not just recruitment
yeah it's gotta come back become it's
got obviously involved to win not me
isn't it but i think but i don't think
anyone listens to this and wants to go
on that journey i think there's space
there to be talking to your
leadership team or like whoever in your
business about how can we get creative
like i want our goal where i'm really
excited for our team to hear and
what how can we structure it in a way
where it's like
yeah where financially we can really
benefit from it i'm happy to have a goal
that i really go for but there's plenty
of space that so the only way i do as
well i'm just on that point just in the
final bit what i heard someone the other
day right saying to me
i'm
i want to be a manager now manager
i'm struggling with how many kpis i've
got to make sure that the team are doing
yeah and and and the team aren't quite
hitting the kpis
that comes down to my kpi world of i
hate kpis in terms of kpi kpi's sake
yeah so if you put the trust in a
manager
to build the to do the team
yeah let them develop together like let
them develop the team rather than
this person suddenly is not making three
calls like he's supposed to
and that will actually allow people to
have freedom to move their career
forward do i mean something you can
become a manager and you think [ __ ] i've
got to make sure this person's hitting
50 calls a day 20 emails that are i've
got a lot of that becomes a
transactional side
and i think sometimes like
i think sometimes difficult for the
managers to develop further
when they're so micromanaged all the
time and that yeah there's too many this
is not just recruitment this happens in
general right you give someone an
opportunity let them go and do it
um so yeah
yeah no really interesting
so
let's talk about the last
decade then
so
obviously told us a bit about the
experience
that you um was going through
got that sort of head of perm position
then didn't quite work out or wasn't
what you wanted
obviously had your
little woman who was 18 months old so
like talk to us about did you have
confidence starting your own recruitment
business was you worried like what was
why a lot of people say
i'll start my own recruitment business
but never actually do it so what what
gave you the courage to take that first
step do you think
well i think uh
i was like a couple of years behind my
like a plum like i always wanted to do
it um and i always thought i could do it
but i went into it thinking right i've
got a
i've got money in the bank for a year
okay
so
in 12-month runway
if you can't make it with myself for the
comment yeah then i'll get back into
recruitment and just be employed
okay um but i really uh
i spent too long trying to think in the
name and i ended up with mrj i wanted
something really cool that i ended up
with with my my initials backwards only
because my my initials forwards someone
else had
so it was like the first four weeks to
try and sort out a bloody name and i was
like what's going on it's ridiculous um
and then
one of the um
but i always thought
i'd do all right
about yourself
yeah
now like one of the uh
few months
in one of uh someone i work with came to
work with me for a bit um and um it was
great like the two of us together
was really good
he um
he moved on he was gonna see something
else and then it was just me for for a
while
how long was it just you for for a
couple of years but you know what
it was probably just under two years
and
it was good like i found it tough
in times like sitting in my in my home
office or when's got itself an office
like a small little office in like local
um
but i had all the like clients i was
working with and we're doing some good
stuff and it was i enjoyed the
flexibility at that point what i mean by
flexibility was
dedicated more time to family and um
that i probably missed out on
but was doing some really good stuff
then i thought right we've got money in
the bank we're going to come let's go
and do this seriously and i went on a
bit of a recruitment drive
but i thought naively let's just go and
get
trainees
and to build a company through trainees
yeah now some of the trainees
he would who since moved on and done
some great things one of them's got his
own company now once in australia he's
got his own company
they were great but
i didn't have time to train him
too focused on the business trying to be
doing everything and it was a disaster
so i made mistakes
so
um and then a mate of mine
who was in property wanted to get into
property recruitment so we thought well
how about i just teach you how to do
recruitment it would come in there we
did like mrj property and again it was
just a bad mistake
so
you know you made mistakes but i've
learned from them so then about
five years ago
we're doing a bit too much of everything
you know money was good right but we're
doing a bit of everything with like one
day
was this one day was that then we had um
i was doing it property recruitment then
it was like
dealing with any sort of tom dick and
aaron he was just like no this is i'm
just not enjoying what i'm doing
i didn't enjoy it i wasn't enjoying like
the people i was working with i've taken
i knew that the people that some of the
people taking were
just bad hires at the time
um so is that right okay
at that point a couple of the guys
who with me
and we wanted to try and build it with
them
and
a third person was coming on
two of them at that point i offered them
do you want to get involved in mrj so
they've now got shares in mrj
and then another lad a couple of years
later got involved in shares as well but
we actually turn around and say right
imagine that we just draw a line under
this business for a minute
and we just do a blunt piece of paper
and and just go right
we have no clients today
but let's go and go and like which
clients like do we actually want to work
with
so we wanted to work with like well
let's go and work with some ecom
companies that we can actually see the
benefit of our work
or
websites or tech companies that we would
actually see
we place developers
when we go on the website that's pretty
cool right we can see the developers
they're actually building what we're
doing
so we did
we called a lot of clients that we
worked with which people thought i was
absolutely mad at the point
but we were just doing it just for
money's sake
it just wasn't really
yeah before we go into the last like
five years then i'm actually seeing
because it seems like just i just want
to make sure that we unpack this a bit
because i feel like people can relate to
it
so yeah
it seems like yeah like thanks for being
so honest and sharing all of that so i
just want to make sure that people
listen to this can i guess learn from
the mistakes that you've made right so
firstly
like
just you said around the positives of
you just smashing out on your own
like flexibility seeing family
money like just talk to us for a second
because i think sometimes people can
underestimate this i think it's
important that we talk about like what
what were the challenges was it the
challenges mentally was it the
challenges i'm just doing this on my own
i've got no one to share the wins with
like what were the actual challenges
that you had to work through of you
being on your own in those first two
years firstly
yeah
not having the buzz of just someone
around you it's tough not having someone
at the end of the phone is is tough
uh
not having a mentor at the time was
was like for me was tough
like
my account is done by my old man so he
was always there as a good advisor he's
been a great advisor throughout the
whole period um live but also last 10
years
you know but
he was my old man and we go to football
together so it was like we needed
something else
um
but i think
eventually
i just lost the buzz of like i needed i
needed something something more
yeah and i thought i didn't just set
this up just to
be a one-man band
and i couldn't just carry on being a
one-man band
like now i ever wanted to be
but
i just missed people
like in kobetov i miss people the
benefit is we've got everyone i still
talk to people all day but the time is
if you just miss people
um what i did love about it was
and i still love about it to be honest
is there's loads of flexibility you pick
and choose whatever you want to do
hour-wise um
one of the things i've always liked i
don't have a uh i don't have a boss
anymore so i don't have to
deal with that
um but if anyone's starting out
themselves or they are them
if they are
a one-man band or a two-man band
my advice would be
don't get a mentor
or go and have someone you can speak to
that you'd look up to respect because
um
if you can
like you've got ideas all the time right
but if you can just go like i've got
this idea what do you think
yeah all they could say is yes or no
but give you some thought behind it but
i didn't really have that except for my
dad the reality is my dad gave me
brilliant advice
but
and you know not many people have that
so my advice to anyone going into a
world of like you know what your dad's
great to get advice
you know when he is he's a specialist in
accounting which was very helpful for me
especially starting out
but having like a real mentor and and
someone you can work with or work
alongside someone
would be my advice do it on your own
isn't tough
yeah so just on that because you
mentioned it a few times gareth having a
real big impact on you like how how
what's been your
so it seems like gareth that was quite
organic you ended up working for the
same business but how did you then how
have you gone about getting a mentor
like is it as simple as identifying and
seeing the people you do aspire to that
and you reached out like how
how did you
how would you so i've only really led
ships
i only realized
a couple years ago
um
the old ceo of rudyard
yeah uh john
started like having like a an hour or
two hour sessions with me about two
years ago we haven't done as much
recently but i haven't needed if i can
come on too why but i think at the point
it was
um
it was really useful but it took me
eight years to get to that point of
realizing that why did it take you so
long to ask for help don't know me it
was because i'm probably too bloody
minded to be fair i think and thought
you know naively think that you know
everything and
yeah i know best
which is like one of my biggest
one of my biggest
weaknesses is
is um
i think that's just a lot of people's is
you know best right your company you
know best
your recruiter you know best
um
what was it that you helped with then
that you least that you least expected
um
telling me to focus on what i'm good at
trying to do too many things was not a
good thing we tried to do some software
it's still live right and
um
just do what you're good at
and me i'm a good recruiter
am i the best manager maybe not
am i the best leader
i don't think i'm the best leader but
i'm a good leader well i'm like a
leading from being like my approach that
i'm a leader from hands-on yeah by
example yeah
yeah i'm not the manager like i'm not
great other things that i just get that
i hate
but this needs to be unpacked at a time
was
to you to grow mrj
you need to release some stuff that
you're doing
ah
delegation you're just trying to hold on
to do too many things everything
everything that's a but you know what
that is one of the biggest problems that
i speak to a lot of
uh
clients entrepreneurs and people and
it's the same same with a lot of people
right yeah it's your baby
why why didn't you why why why were you
like rough self-reflection like why
would you always want it was it because
you just didn't feel like anyone could
do it as good as you or you felt like
you could only do it in the way that it
needed to be done
i think
yeah i think i just thought well i'm the
best at doing it and did my
relationships and that and that and that
just takes away
yeah i think it just takes you like
trust with your stuff you need to put
more trust in them and you know i've got
people who are better than me now
recruitment
you know and
they're they're flying they're doing
great stuff and um
but i just needed it took me a time to
put trust in them it's just like
you build a relationship you never want
that relationship to win right so
yeah but i think
talking to john i was just remembering
going
around to me and said
i'm going to go and build a software
platform three years like the year
before i
called with john john would have said
you're bloody mad
your company's going like this
just continue going like that but what
happened was we lost our focus
because we were trying to do other
things right and we thought
so i was like right you're right
you're right keep the focus of where
you're going keep that path the way
you're going but having someone to to
basically bollocky in a way
and yeah and put you on that path is
important it just took me a long time to
get there
but yeah
you know i think if i look back at
that first chat with john was brilliant
and i can pick up the phone to john
anytime you know and and i know that
john would just be giving me an honest
an opinion and i think what happened
from there is
suddenly
the client relationships
and now i'm handled by the majority of
the team
i've got a couple that i do myself
but the team do it like and
and then september last year
um
i was just like
just not enjoying doing i'm just not
enjoying doing this management side and
the operational side and
having this official title md
so
um
we appointed one of the lads so one of
the lads he's he's got a 10 grand
turn around and said mate
you you love all the management
operational side i want to step back and
just want you to own it all
and i just don't get involved in it at
all anymore
at all and i think what's happened
oh mate it's the best decision i've ever
made the best thing i ever made because
he deals with all the crap i just have
the fun now so um and he deals with like
he's our chief of staff i was always the
man you're chief of staff you you you're
managing the people you're making sure
they've got all the tools you're making
sure that they're in the right place i'm
leading from a
i'm leading the sales activity with the
team
you're you're supporting them in a way
and leading it and it's just released me
massively so i think my advice to anyone
starting up would be if you can get an
advisor get one
yeah
um
not every advisor is gonna be the right
advisor
you know i think
other people's opinions get people's
thoughts like try and make it it's not
just you
um
um john john was brilliant for me
um
you know
but over time i've also got a few of the
guys and girls i've been talking to who
who've been really good um
you know and we're talking to someone
else at the moment who may come full
full-time on board but i've just got
involved in as well in in a uh
in a consultancy
as like an advisor funny enough
because they're you know and i've
learned a lot about building the startup
of what it was and the mistakes i made
so i'm hoping that they can use my
experience
to keep them on it i feel like the way
what how i wrap that up is yeah try and
like don't feel like you know it all
would not be open-minded to get other
people's thoughts and
these types it only takes one thing for
it to be worthwhile speaking to someone
absolutely
don't hold on don't try and like do
everything or hold on to like all of the
things because you think you can do it
best if you do want to if you do want to
grow a business a recruitment business
then you're going to have to trust other
people even though there may be some
hiccups along the way and you think i
could do this but long term yeah
yeah and then the other thing
was then like you said like having a
real focus like i feel like recruitment
businesses they're all
entrepreneurs and people can be really
open-minded and see opportunities and
they can go
and try and take those opportunities but
then something else is gonna um be
affected so having a real focus and
sticking to it
so what i want to ask you then and then
i want to go into the um
the sort of last few years because it
feels like you've
just really turned the real positive
corner in the last couple of years so i
guess
how would you sum up then like the
learnings from those hiring mistakes so
after that two year period where it was
just like you mainly
then you were like right i'm gonna like
you start growing this like it's just me
not enjoying it let's get some people in
blah blah and you said
like it's just so many different
failures in there like what were the
because i think a lot of people can
learn from that what were they like one
three key things that i'm sure you've
now used when growing your recruitment
business more recently
uh if you've got time say trainees if
you don't have time don't take them okay
guys yeah
because
someone said it to me the other day
right
a client said to me uh because he posted
something on linkedin and i pulled him
up on it
and there was another like recruitment
bashing he went you know the problem is
joe
this guy's he's too young he's got no
experience got no idea what he's talking
about he's trying to to preach to me
and i was like you'll get that people
got to be given opportunities
so
people who want to get in the industry
need to be given opportunities but don't
take them at the beginning if you don't
have time to train them just because
they're cheap yeah
you know i'd prefer if i look back i'd
prefer to spend
more money on more experienced people to
start with
you are gonna who can help you drive
your business to then allow you more
juniors so that's the first thing
focus on
focus on what you're good at and get
people who are really passionate about
it
and what i mean by that is
um people go into a cream and go yeah i
want to make loads of money
so why do you want to get into it
recruitment i think it's a really good
industry
well
you've got to be really interested in
the marketplace you've got to be part of
the market
so
make sure you've got a platform that
allows your teams
to go and develop within the industry
so that's why we're involved into
various different events not because
we don't use it as a recruitment uh
method like a lot of agencies do which
is like oh we'll set up this risk news
we'll settle this uh
this uh meet up so we can go and get
loads of business from it which we're
here all the time but for me it's about
actually learning more being better at
what we do
and so allowing so making sure you've
got a platform in place to allow that to
happen in the company
um
my biggest mistake i think i made was
not taking too seriously at the
beginning
uh
i thought it was dead easy
because
first year we made some money we thought
we might as well spend it go and get
people
and it's just just easy
and and probably became a bit lazy
because money can make you lazy
sometimes yeah you can do it so you make
mistakes because you think
you know
they're always going to use me it's fine
but you're only as good as the last deal
so you've got to keep it going
um
well i think we just had we hired some
really good people
at the time
we but we
probably didn't give them a platform to
grow as much as we probably as i
probably should have done
which is why they they moved on but that
comes down to my own
i'm not gonna release anything i'm not
gonna let anything go
but that's what i needed i needed
someone to basically turn around to me
and go you're not gonna grow
until you allow
others to to develop and do things and
take ownership and do that
but that just came with with experience
i think
yeah all the time
but don't be afraid to make mistakes
don't be afraid to make mistakes mate
like
i i was always nervous about making
mistakes which is why i didn't let
others manage stuff
but people could only learn it to make a
mistake and we can always rectify it
but also as a business you're always
going to make mistakes
yeah it don't matter if you
don't matter if you're 100 million pound
profit company 20 years old
or you're or you're starting up you're
still going to make mistakes
um
so
let's talk about let's finish up this
the last 15 minutes they're talking
about some of the breakthroughs then
maybe that you've
had in the last couple years it seems
like you've been on the real jet light
you're right your own personal real
journey it feels like getting like
getting out of your own way trusting
people
like letting people yeah take the range
recognizing what people are better at
so i think obviously it takes there's a
lot of people that would have continued
to be
jody who was who was like the beginning
of this journey like still 10 15 years
from now do you know what i mean so like
definitely hats off to you too
and i'm sure yeah clearly it wasn't easy
but you've you've worked through it and
you've been able to do it but there will
still be people that
won't get out of their own way
um
like
talk to us about
the last couple of years then like
really interested in this sort of uh
talent piece yeah i think because i
think that's i do feel like more and
more recruitment businesses
uh are doing
things like that uh so i'd be love to
hear sort of your experience of that and
and how that sort of product and service
came about
but then i guess just obviously you
mentioned around grant and that being a
pivotal moment where
you've you let someone own the
operations and chief of people and these
types of things that was really pivotal
but i guess any other pivotal moments
you think that maybe wouldn't have
happened
when jody had the mindset he did five
six seven years ago
yeah fun
so
going to give you about four years where
it started properly i think to where we
are today
so if you remember i said like we
basically ripped up what we were doing
yeah yeah you decided right let's let's
build a place that we want to work for
people work for so people always say
it's about 10 years unbelievable but i'd
like forget the years right if we would
we would we would nearly change the name
about four or five years ago and in
effect we're going to start fresh so i
always go back you know what
let's go with let's go we're a
five-year-old company
and then we're like right what do we
really want to do we want to work with
companies and we had a goal in mind did
we we had a few targets that we wanted
to do
and one of the key targets was money
supermarket moving to manchester from
from chester we thought how great would
it be for us to get money supermarket
like it's the most used website in the
uk in terms of comparison what you know
and let's go and get it and we've got it
there was a platform for mrj to be put
suddenly going [ __ ] with this mrj
you know and then off the back of that
we then um we started working with a few
startups so we had some startups in
manchester we were like okay well let's
go and pick the companies we really want
to be working with we're some really
cool startups um
and then it's just gone on from there
because reputation wise
like we have
we don't do cold calling
which is going to be a surprising thing
to a lot of people out there right but
our
we don't i don't target my team
on cold calling
like
99 percent of them
right this is like it's probably like
don't do call the woman nine percent of
our clients
have come from
the last four years recommendations
from work that we've done and people
will work with right
we don't have kpis we don't i don't care
how many people i really don't care how
many calls people make i mean emails are
sent i really don't care because it's
irrelevant
it's completely irrelevant many
supermarkets still four years later are
working with us so for me we're doing
something right
and off the back of that we've now got
hermes passes delivery his example came
off the back of a referral from morris
supermarket so they've all come from
referrals right
but then you asked me about mrj tallinn
and we started working some startups and
had a contact he was setting up a
company push doctor
and i thought about this model i'd heard
about this model
and i've never really done it so push
doctor we wanted to launch in manchester
and i was like
eric got an idea how about we just do
like a bit of a different type of model
where we have someone dedicated on site
you pay us a monthly fee and we we own
the whole thing for you and we held the
growth and three people start up to 120
people
um which is a couple of years and we did
everything from tech to
marketing to even helping customer
service it was a really on-site
um model
and it was great so then we were like
right
this was coming to the end but i was
thinking you know you did a lot of them
they're a project but this was like a
two-year project yeah and i was like
right i'm gonna go and set up a proper
on-site talent arm
yeah um
and
um
i met someone
who would work with in the past
and i was and i was and i was about to
offer him the job
and uh honestly
and i don't mind putting on him he sees
it he knows full well i got shots on
because i told that we had the plan we
had companies about to go and target
next minute um
he's uh directed for talentful
in manchester
right
and i'll let him boom it right
really so he annoyed me
don't trust everyone don't trust
everything right as i always say so i'm
a bit more wary about
um yeah yes sir people are take on
anyway it happened so we put us back in
our plan but we always had a plan to do
this on-site talent partnership but what
we've focused on is right okay we've got
these clients we're going to build our
reputation up with these various
different clients over time
which is what we've done and the guys
done some great stuff like some mega
mega stuff
over the last
four years has been great i think the
best thing that we did was
there's four of us mrj so everyone sees
mrj is like
joe's ceo founder but really for me it's
four of us
you know it's got three other
shareholders and there is as important
as i am to the company and i think that
was really um
if i look back at the beginning
would have done it myself again no i've
definitely done it with someone
or two or three people yeah
and because
we share
like
we share the care and love about what
we're trying to do and we're invested in
it and i know these guys aren't going
i've always had his dad what happens if
we give too much and then someone goes
you know what you know because he was a
small company and
and that happened so one of my guys left
went to arrival
one day they tapped into my recruitment
database
and um
and tried to take take data which wasn't
great so i got burned a few times along
the way so just be wary you trust but i
always have this plan mrj talon there
must be a market for it and
you know what we've um
we did our first one like properly one
at the start of 2020
and it started as a three-month
engagement it's coming to the end this
month she's been on site 18 months
because of the work that she's done and
she's not just found people she's helped
build a talent brand she's going to tell
her acquisition do it
and
we've been on site become i've been
outside personally with company
uh since september always always wanted
to open in manchester
why do you think that's becoming more
and more popular do you think because i
do i'm sure you've seen it right it's
like what you put on your
linkedin is like yeah like you said like
push doctor via mrj i'm i'm sure you've
noticed that i'm seeing more and more
yeah yeah like why
like do you think it's so it's like
you're actually really
solving more problems for a business
which is why
like it i don't know like why did you
just have their own internal yeah i
think what happens is i think
recruitment
companies and agents and consultants
make such a it can
delve into networks that
um that others don't and that's why
we're we're very valuable right
so yeah
but what i think happens sometimes is
you're using these partners then you
want to save cost
yeah so we want to bring in internal
recruiters but instead of a recruiter
could cost you 30 40 50 grand basic on
the bottom line
but what happens in three months time
when
the project would find those 10 people's
finished what do we do with that person
i think that's a lot of mindsets
especially startups if you go it's like
a project project does that mean do you
want me yeah yes it's like it's a lot
more flexible it's like they can do it
like yeah that helps cash flow
what i found is is why
our model is is different to some others
like our model is
fixed fee
per month to get a consortium
placement and then for placement but
it's fixed fee
well
i'm sure that's a bit slightly a bit
more reduced than what it would be yeah
so they get they get everything they get
advertising they get um
[Music]
the whole sort of job job profile job
specs and everything completely
redefined we get brand out there we've
got a marketing guy who puts all the
mountain activity behind it
we
um we then found the people but we're
motivated still to find people rather
than just doing talon brand
and what happens sometimes what i've
found is yeah inside
we have internal talent partners i can
never i can't get my hair on this right
sometimes you have internal talent
partners
yeah
who don't recruit
but they then use recruiters
so what's the point of them
because what are they doing are they
doing like they're on boarding and
they're just going to be practicing oh
we'll do the brand we'll do the
onboarding process we do the recruitment
interview process
so it's costing them more money and then
when the project's finished what happens
so you know they're there but what
happens there's no roles to recruit yeah
we need to build the brand and those
side of things so i just so we tried it
with a few companies and it's worked
really well and we're we're live with
four companies now
um
what well the deliverables out of
interest like you don't have to go into
all the detail but what are the i think
people would be interested in like okay
so if i if i did i feel like there would
be things that i could add value on if
i'm listening to this but like what what
would be the deliverables that you do is
it does it varies we're going to get x
number of cvs per month we're going to
get x number of interviews per month for
you what are the typical integrables
uh so we don't we don't get focused on
i don't put anything like that in place
it's about
yeah
because
uh well one of them we obviously
the cto said to me at the beginning i
don't want you
i want this other recruiter
because he's my mate but everyone else
what he does so it for like six months
he was going how's he three to one ratio
going i was a three-to-one ratio between
uh like siri two replacements and again
it became a laughing joke
uh until they realized that our ratios
were better
and i finally actually we're not just
there to we're finding the people
we don't get tired of how many
candidates we find
um
we don't get tired like in terms of
you we could find them 10 people
in a month but 10 people don't get a job
what's the point
yeah we'll just focus on on um on
results and results of finding the
people within a certain amount of time
so we like to say that
on average we're now
placing candidates from role coming out
to
placement is around 18 to 19 days across
everything
that's
that's from
initial engagement in terms of we're
going there then we've got to get all
the specs so is it we'll sign up this
role right then we're going to get all
the specs and then we'll get the updates
done then we get the pre ins and to
prove that and all these process on
average
it's about 18 19. some of them are about
11 12 days
some are a bit more so that's why it's
averaging out
before
so i look a bit more about how can we
reduce time to higher time to higher
yeah so i'm looking at times higher so
you can send as many cvs you want but
it's irrelevant
you know i mean that's a great
deliverable isn't it tell me what your
current time to hire is yes it's for you
bring it down okay
so it's time to hire and it's time to
hire is improving and the right sort of
cost
that's that's uh um that's our case
study that we go in with with everyone
rather than
oh you know what in september we sent
out uh
we sent out 45 cvs
yeah but how many people do you place oh
you didn't place anyone but we did 45
cvs oh well
great at least you've got some people
interested
i don't know i mean
yeah so yeah
so talent's developing it's a developing
model um
we're doing some great stuff yeah it
doesn't come without its issues as well
sometimes you know i think you know
what i've come to realize is
recruiter you're very much on the
outside and you don't see what has to go
in
from the inside
so what it's actually done is it's
enabled my team in general for the core
days
is that
when sometimes they get frustrated
because they haven't had feedback after
the 48 hours and they'll promise that
they really understand the internal now
they get it
yeah i understand that actually things
could be going on inside so for one of
them i've got uh i've got my team's
account got my email address i've got
that means with them all the time and
see what's going on
but we understand that better so i think
we become better we've become a better
company in the last 18 months because
eight
we've uh we've kept the same team
we've grown the team but we haven't had
a revolving door
and actually we've got better together
but b um
we understand recruitment i think our
team
have been more understanding of what
goes on
rather than
the transactional recruiter who's
getting really pissed off because i
cannot get any feedback in 36 i was i've
got no interest in working with you
anymore i know certain companies in
manchester at the moment who were
messaging companies around there going
you feel that's too slow got no interest
in working with you thanks for your time
right but you know what's going to
happen what happens in six months time
when the companies they're working with
now stop recruiting
and the desperate
but like things things happen
so i mean not everything
happens just how you want it to happen
so i think you need to have that more
understanding so tolerance going great i
think um
recruitment side like mlj recruitment
which is our
you know i'd say is our
core is doing really good like though
the guys are doing brilliant stuff at
the minute um
and then we just got involved with the
new consultancy called nebula
um we've been talking to the guys for
about eight weeks they are dis like
digital consultancy official product
consultancy um started up what two weeks
ago three weeks ago now
um going into places and putting like
real product teams on site um
three super super bright guys
like super super bright intelligent guys
um
and you know i think
tuesday wednesday next week we should
sign our first client on board in three
weeks which is amazing and it's in
america
will be our first one
we should be live in san fran in like
four weeks for our first first uh client
project
um
and that's great because it's it's given
me personally some
some new skills of like more of like
advising
uh but also from a recruitment point of
view we're gonna ramp up pretty quickly
and that business overlays the plan as
well um
which is which is great
so as we come to the end here i guess
just just find the question interesting
your thoughts i think one i think you've
been on such an interesting journey so
thanks for
sort of sharing the the journey that
you've been on and being sorry
um
i guess where look you've been in
recruiting for a long time clearly
you're someone that's really gone on
your own personal journey you've been
open-minded to
how you can do things better and improve
and these types of things like where
where do you see recruitment going in
the next sort of decade do you think
what are you thinking about
um
[Music]
so everyone keeps saying to me oh my god
technology is literally going to remove
the recruiter
which i just think is rubbish like that
that's my opinion right technology will
enhance the industry and enhance
people's decision-making maybe but it's
not going to replace a recruiter
like i can never imagine a place and
maybe i'm just naive but i could never
imagine
the
the interview the one-to-one interview
with a manager and a candidate will be
replaced just by technology
which is what people keep telling me
so
we'll enable the human elements of it i
think it will just really yeah it will
make it yeah
that
it's
where nothing's going on in 10 years so
talent partnership is a big thing for me
um
i think what i'm finding is what so
telling partners is one
and um don't get too much of my secrets
away but that's where that's all going
to be our a big drive for the next for
the next few years i think um yeah
you know and we're learning on the job
doing that we're making like i said
we're making some mistakes in that area
but we're getting better as well
um
i think
that because what i'm noticing is less
and less
kpi heavy
companies
is um is a good thing
but i also think that the industry is
becoming i think what happened in colby
times is
a lot of crap went out of the industry
yeah
it did
and i think that's a good thing
because
i've seen less recruitment bashing
because i think
people actually uh there's better people
in the industry
you're always going to get in any
industry you go into there's going to be
some
it's not everyone's going to be perfect
but i think if you can keep growing
nurturing training and really showing
time to develop and health and
well-being and that's a big thing
but
mate where do i think it'd be in 10
years i don't know where it's going to
be in like a week's time like it's like
it changes by the day right
yeah
like we changed like things happen all
the time i um
there's something exciting that's going
on on monday in our places
we didn't think was going to happen then
wednesday we've got a pitch with
something which could turn into
something ridiculously big potentially
which
which can change our model again so
we've got to evolve with it but
i think the talent partnership thing is
is definitely my thing that i'm really
excited about
and
i'd really like to see
a lot more of a
um
a lot more investment in in training of
and and for the industry but that's just
in every industry as a whole
which which i think is really important
because
don't expect my final thing is i always
say just don't expect that someone's
just gonna know how to do it you've got
if you're gonna take someone on you've
gotta give them time i made that mistake
i made that mistake and i still do it
sometimes it's like you're paying this
person money you expect it's going to be
done like that
yeah have you spent any time with him to
invest in them
no give people a chance a real challenge
give people a chance but like it's
difficult to answer me but i do think
the talent partnership model
is for me where it's going to be a
massive marketplace open in 10 years
time
i'd be shocked if there's not a lot more
of that those talent partnerships yeah
that makes sense yeah yeah for sure
um
jody's been an absolute pleasure thank
you so much thank you
thanks for uh being super honest and
really excited to to see how
you and your business evolves
really good appreciate it and uh you
have a great weekend